what is capitalism is it boundless
luxury private ownership free trade only
the powerful prevail for many capitalism
is like a beast of prey according to the
father of economics Adam Smith profit
drives the economy and self-interest is
the engine for prosperity if we all
apply rational self-interest everyone
benefits profit was also key for the
German philosopher Karl Marx according
to Marx capital accumulation is ongoing
and benefits only the factory owner to
generate surplus value capitalists
exploit everyone and everything
workers machines and natural resources
surplus-value according to Marx is
generated on the free market when the
product is sold capitalism means
constant competition and price is
determined by supply and demand the
winner is the factory owner who Spurs
ever greater profits and ever higher
production everyone else loses this is
how Marx understood early unfettered
capitalism these criticisms
notwithstanding most countries in the
world today are more or less capitalist
economies
the downsides remain competitors go
bankrupt workers receive little of the
surplus value that's been generated
that's intrinsic to the system and
there's more low wages inequality
poverty environmental destruction
financial crisis the rise of monopolies
today laws and rules are imposed to
reform capitalism and tame it but time
and again the beasts of prey breaks
through its fetters
[Music]